[Müzik]
Şimdi ikinci konuşmamızı da ben takdim
etmekten gerçekten çok onur duyuyorum Bu
ikinci konuşmacı Hem bir Veli Aynı
zamanda da Beyaz Fırın markasının 5
nesil temsilcisi Eee kendisi Natali suda
e ve eğitim hayatını natal Hanım eğitim
hayatını sonlandırdıktan sonra beyaz
Fırın'ın ürün geliştirme ve pazarlama
sorumlusu olarak göreve başlamış e
Yıllar İçinde markanın vizyon ve
misyonunun belirlenmesinde önemli bir
rol oynamıştır 2007'den itibaren beyaz
fırının genel müdürü olan Natalie ston
of su da beyaz fırını dört mağazadan
2022 itibariyle bütün İstanbul genelinde
11 mağazaya çıkarmıştır e suda Hanım
Natali suda Hanım sadece beyaz fırının
gelişiminde etkili olmamış aynı zamanda
D tane kitap yayınlamış e beyaz fırın
braser ve şokola Ş Natali markalarının
yaratılmasına öncülük etmiş Eee ve 2022
yılında da Natali ile tatlı tuzlu sohbet
sobet adı bir pod yayınlamaya
başlamıştır işte karşımızda
Nat Çok teşekkür
ederim Evet ben natal stoyan bu okulda
ik tane de kızım var Bu arada aynı
zamanda velisiyim de çok teşekkür ederim
davet ettiğiniz
için evet asırlık
asaı bir firmanın
nes yim Eee ve temsilcisiyim Eee Aslında
hepimizin bildiği klasik bir hikayedir
Eee aile büyükleri ortada bir iş vardır
ve aile büyükleri
Eee çocuklarının işin başına geçmesini
ister çocuklarının o işi Aslında seviyor
ya da sevmiyor olmasından bağımsız
olarak Eee o işin o çocuğa ihtiyacı
vardır Eee fakat kimse çocuğa sormaz o
işi seviyor mu sevmiyor mu diye
Eee Kimisi
ailesine yalan söyler bambaşka bir
kariyerin peşinde koşar ve günün sonunda
Eee bambaşka bir insan olarak onların
karşısına çıkıp kimi zaman hayal
kırıklığına uğratır kimi zaman da hayal
kırıklığına uğrayan kendisidir e Aslında
o hiç
sevmediği
işle işe mahkum kalmıştır Eee ve
hayatını Hayallerinden mahrum bir
şekilde devam ettirir Ben şanslıydım E
çünkü benim Hikayem mutlu sonla
bitenlerden ama
Eee o şansı da biraz anlatmak istiyorum
size Eee ailem iki asırdır yeme içme
sektöründe ve ben Eee yaklaşık Eee 11-12
yaşlarındaydı İlkokulu yeni bitirmiştim
Eee ve E böyle yemeğe karşı mutfağa
karşı inanılmaz bir e heyecan duyuyordum
ama çok da farkında değildim anneannemin
arkadaşları yemek bir reçel yaparlar
reçel anlatırlar ben pür dikkat Onu
dinlerim bu İncir Reçeli Şimdi tam da
zamanı Eee onun yapımına dikkat ederim
bir yemek programı Eee olur televizyonda
ki o zamanlar Şimdiki gibi değil çok sık
çok sığdı çok azdı programlar Eee onlara
izlerim ve kendimi unuturum Aslında
bunlar olurken ya da annemin arkadaşları
gelir eve anne dur sen girme mutfağa ben
yaparım sizin için der ve o mutfakta
yine Eee kendimi unuturum yedirme yemek
e bakmayın böyle olduğuma çok
çabalıyorum
Aslında buralarda
gezinebilir Tutku Eee
ve Aslında hepimiz için
Eee nerede Kendinizden geçtiğinizi fark
ettiğiniz an tutkunuzu bulduğunuz nokta
o yüzden dakikaların nasıl geçtiğini
fark etmediğiniz e Her neyse onun
tutkunu olduğunu bilip peşinden Eee
kolaylıkla gidebilirsiniz çünkü hep
derttir tutkum ne benim acaba Özellikle
bu yaşlarda keşfetmek büyük bir konu Eee
ben o zaman tabii şimdi geriye dönüp
baktığımda Evet benim tutkumm Muş
dakikaları Eee saymadığı zamanlar
Eee Peki şimdi siz duyar gibiyim hepiniz
diyorsunuz ki ya ne kadar şanslıymış sın
sen sonuçta ortada bir aile işi varmış E
sen de yemeyi seviyor mus yapmayı
seviyormuşsun
Eee Dolayısıyla Oh işte mis gibi tam
denk geldi pek de öyle değil aslında
Çünkü benim ailemden Bana Kalan İş
aslında küçük bir poğaça börek çörek
fırını Yani bir esnaf Dükkanı
Eee ve benim yapmayı sevdiğim hayal
ettiğim B çok daha kadınsı çok daha
rafine bir şey olsun istediğim noktanın
çok uzağında Eee kuru poğaçalar an
atılıyor
işte ben çok daha rafine bir şeyler
istiyorum Oysa ki o dönemde Peki ne
yapacağız
Eee Tabii 5 nesil olmak çok güzel ama
bir de önde bir 4 nesil var ve o 4 nesil
her zaman sizin Eee önünüzü haklı olarak
açmıyor
Eee baba dedim ben yeni bir yerler
yapmak istiyorum Yeni bir dükkan açmak
istiyorum Bir de hep Eee Avrupa
yakasında okumuşum eee e Avrupa
yakasında bir şey istiyorum Eee Fakat
babam eminim ki emlakçıları dolaşıyordu
ve benim hani ayağımı önden bir kaydırı
oldu ki hiçbir şey yapamayız diye Eee
dükkan açamadım Beyaz Fırın Neticede ilk
5 sene işe başladıktan 2000'li yıllarda
oluyor bu fakat Eee işte beyaz fırına da
zarar vermeyeyim Eee diye bir girişim
Eee de bulundum O da şuydu eee küçük bir
e küçük değil ama bir dükkan kiraladım
Eee izin verdi Babam da izin vermesinin
nedeni beyaz türünü Aslında riske
atmayacak
Eee o zaman
Eee mutfak Ekipmanları satan
profesyonellere mutfak Ekipmanları satan
bir firmamız var Eee dedim ki Eee neden
olmasın profesyonellere satıyorlar issa
Eee Ben ev kadınlarına da eee bir
organizasyon yapabilirim ve bir dükkan
açarım Hadi adı da beyaz mutfak olur
Orada da kadınlara işte ev hanımlarına
meraklılarına bu işin Şimdiki gibi öyle
kurslar filan da yok beyaz fırının
ustalarıyla da Eee birlikte mutfağa
giderim eee bir yanda kurs olur öbür
tarafta mutfak Ekipmanları olur bir
tarafta da işte böyle bir 20 metrekare
de lütf ettim beyaz fırını köşeye koydum
fakat
Eee aslında Çok da iyi hesaplanmamış eee
bir işin biraz hızlı hareket edilmiş eee
o dönemde gençliğin heyecanıyla
kendini biraz da aslında Hem kendine
belki Hem de aileye karşı o 45 yıl olmuş
ben yeni hiçbir şey yapamamış bir şey
katamam hissiyle
eee yapmış olduğum bir girişimde
nedenlerini saymayacağız
oldum Aslında ve beyaz mutfak
Eee iyi bir noktaya gidemedi e 56 ay
içinde o 20 metrekare küçücük Beyaz
Fırın benim kurtarıcım oldu ve onu
kaldıraç olarak kullandım e kendimi
batırdığımız Beyaz Fırın sayesinde
çıkardım ve 20 metrekarelik Beyaz Fırın
400 metrekareyi eline geçirdi ve 6 ay
sonra çok şükür ki e Aslında ben çok
büyük bir para batırabilir diim Eee ama
batırmadan beyaz sürün sayesinde
batırmadan
Eee ama tabii o zaman bir suçluluk
Duygum da vardı eım yani pek de anlatmam
bunu aslında ama azımsanmayacak bir
arabam da güzel de bir arabam vardı o
yaşlar için
Eee ve Arabamı sattım parayı da gittim
babama verdim Dedim ki hani bu senin
sana
uğrattığını için Hiç değilse bir kısmını
Eee karşılar Aslında orada şöyle bir şey
vardı Eee biraz kendimi cezalandırma
biraz eğitme Belki babam da bu eğitimime
izin verdi demedi ki Aman kızım Boş ver
sen arabanla devam et değil O cezayı
çekmeme müsaade etti Eee ben de aslında
cumartesi pazarları dahil olmak üzere
Arabamı sattım o Dükkanın içine girdim 6
ay O dükkan iş yapana kadar ben
cumartesi pazar dahil çalışmaya devam
ettim bu benim için hem biraz terapi
gibi oldu aslında akışta kal almak
başarısızlığı yani şu olabilirdi Çünkü
ben başarısız oldum başarısız olduysam H
oyuncaklarımı alıp eve gideyim Hani
küseyim öyle bir şey yapmadım e o
başarısızlıkla yüzleştim ve yola devam
ettim aslında akışta kalmama müsaade
etti beyaz fırım ve orada çalışma hali
Eee tüm bunların sonunda Aslında anladım
ki Eee düşmekten korkm lazım insanın
asıl korkması gereken şey düşmekten
korkup düştükten sonra kalkmaktan
korkmak o cesareti gösterememek korkmak
gerçekten hata yapmak çok değerli ben
bir hata
yapmıştım ama tabii hata yapmak önemli
ama aynı hataları benzer hataları
defalarca da tekrar etmemek
gerekiyor doı sonrasında çok uzun bir
inceleme dönemi oldu benim için
raporların çok önemli olduğu analizin
çok önemli olduğu eee bir dönemi yaşadım
Eee ve Eee Tam da Eee o yıllar Starbucks
ve zincir kahvelerin Eee Artık yavaş
yavaş İstanbul'da olmaya oluşmaya
başladığı yayılmaya başladığı yeme içme
hayatının evlerden dışarı dışarıya
kafelere taşınmaya başladığı bir dönem
Eee o zamana kadar kahvaltı hafta sonu
Kahvaltıları evlerde yapılır E ama yavaş
yavaş artık 2005'den sonra
eee dışarıda yapılmaya başlanmıştı
E ben de ble bakıyorum analiz ediyorum
Fakat biraz da babamı dönüyorum
yokluyorum hiç yumurta koyayım istiyorum
kahvaltı ürünleri koyayım istiyorum hiç
oralı olmuyor benle eee bir gün cesaret
ettim dedim ki baba dedim bizim bunları
koymamız lazım Bu hayat değişmeye
başladı artık masa sandalyeler koymamız
lazım dışarıya Eee sen dedi yumurta
koyup dedi benim poğaçam böreğimi
çöreğimi mi bitireceksin baba dedim ben
bitirmezsen bir gün biri bitirecek merak
etme gel biz şunu efendi efendi koyalım
Eee Dolayısıyla Yok öyle böyle falan
derken ikna edemedim e ve epey bir zaman
Eee Biz bunu başaramadık sonra bir
fırsatını yakaladım
eee Onun da E biraz yumuşak karnının
olduğu bir döneme denk getirdim ve biz o
yumurtaları öyle böyle Koyduk e ve zaman
içinde marka
Eee işte Self servisten masa servisine
geçti önce yumurtaları koyduk Ondan
sonra yemek kahvaltı koyduk Ondan sonra
yemek koyduk falan derken Eee işte ben
işe başladığımda ik mağazayı son 11
mağazaya kadar Eee yükseldik ama bütün
bunlar olurken hiçbiri aslında kolay
olmadı Ben bir şeye inanmıştım Eee önce
başarısız oldum Eee ve Aslında orada
tökezledim ama bırakmadım
Eee devam ettim
Eee ve başardım sonunda ama orada
hakikaten şurada teslim olabilirdim Eee
her şey çok güzel giderken Çünkü aslında
devam etmek kolaydır motivasyonunuz
yüksek olur her şey güzel giderken ama
bir şeyler ters gitmeye başladığı zaman
o Azmi kararlılığı göstermek
Eee çok zordur fırtına başladığı zaman
fırtınada devam etmeye Eee devam etme
konusunda Azimli olmak gerçekten Aslında
tutkunuz olup olmadığının çok iyi bir
Eee kriteridir benim tutkum Eee bu
konuda beni Eee destekledi
Eee size benim hayat bu iş hayatı da ydı
ama bundan önce de bir sporculuk
geçmişim vardı Eee profesyonel olarak
voleybol oynamıştım sonra bir sakatlık
sebebiyle Eee kötü bir sakatlıkla
bırakmak zorunda kaldım sizlere biraz da
yakın olsun istiyorum Daha sizin Eee
hayatınızın içinden şu andaki döneminiz
ilişkin o ilinti yi kurabilir diye çünkü
ben geriye dönünce o ilinti yi
kurabildim ileri gittim ve geri gittim
Eee voleybolu çok seviyordum
Eee seçilme nedenim de aslında uzun
boylu olmamdı bir de Solak olmamdı
voleybol basketbol gibi sporlarda
bilirsiniz hani çok önemlidir Eee Solak
olmak Çünkü herkese Ters Gelir fakat Eee
uzun boyluyum solağım fakat Müthiş
derecede yeteneksizim Eee uzun boylu
olmak da çok dezavantajdır bir taraftan
Çünkü elinize kolunuza geç hakim
olursunuz
Eee sonra avantaja dönüşür
eee Fakat çok seviyorum O takım
ortamında olmayı çok seviyorum topla
buluşma anını çok seviyorum
Eee deplasmana gitmeyi maça çıkmayı çok
seviyorum fakat hep ikinci Yani hep
ikinci altı dayım hiçbir zaman asıl
kadroda olamıyorum çok çalıştım Yani
bunu söylemem lazım bu kadar çok
sevdiğimi bildiğim şey için o yaşlarda
böle 14 yaşlarında falandım Eee çok
çalıştım Eee Ve sonunda çok Ç iyi bir e
sporcu oldum
Eee
avantajlarımız dezavantaj
[Müzik]
avantajlarımız ve Aslında ideal
koşulları oluşturdum Eee ve sporculuk
Hayatım beni Aslında İş hayatına bu
anlamda
Eee alıştırdı doğuştan bir yeteneğim
olmayabilirdi Eee ama yeteneksiz olmam
sporcu olmama engel miydi Hayır değildi
Eee son söz olarak şunu sizlere söylemek
istiyorum Eee Aslında elinizde neler
olduğuna bakmanız çok önemli önce onlara
bakın Sonra diğer tarafta Eee ailenizle
gelenler kişilik özellikleriniz
yetkinlik
etrafınızdaki insanlar kimlerle temasta
olduğunuz Eee Hangi ortamın içinde
olduğunuz zayıf ve güçlü yönlerinizi
gerçekten objektif değerlerle ortaya
koyun kendiniz bunu sağlayamıyorsunuz
[Müzik]
ki Eee artık sürekli bir eğitimin
içindeyiz E artık okula Bize şu
öğretildi hep okul üniversite iş hayatı
yani eğitim Aslında üniversiteden sonra
Teknik olarak bitiyor gibi öğretildi
bizim neslimize Aslında böyle bir şey
yok şu anda Geldiğimiz noktada Biz
hepimiz hayat boyu öğrenciler Eee
Dolayısıyla zayıf yönlerimizi Eee
geliştirmemiz de Eee bizi Aslında güçlü
kılacak eee unsurların başında geliyor
Eee tüm Bunların içinde sanırım Neden
olmasını Eee mesajını vermişimdir diye
düşünüyorum dinlediğiniz için çok
teşekkür
[Alkış]
ederim